[Musique]
bonsoir mercredi 18 mars bienvenue pour
cette édition spéciale sur tv 78
consacrée à la pandémie de coronavirus
dans les yvelines
la france et le département placé en
confinement depuis hier midi pour
endiguer la progression du coc vide 19
le nombre de cas progresse en ile de
france plus 415 en 24 heures entre lundi
et mardi 15 heures à noter tout de même
que cette hausse est moins importante
que celle constatée pour la journée
précédente au dernier point publié hier
par santé publique france 2 mille cent
soixante dix sept personnes sont
contaminées par le coronavirus dans la
région et vous l'avez sûrement constaté
depuis hier peu de monde dans les rues
les sorties sont limités au strict
essentiel et doivent se ferme et uni
d'une attestation sur l'honneur qui peut
être contrôlé par les forces de l'ordre
chaque contrevenant s'expose désormais à
135 euros damende majorée à 375 euros
parmi les services qui reste ouvert
pendant cette période de confinement et
les stations service malgré la baisse
des prix à la pompe est la limitation
des déplacements pousse les citoyens à
ne pas utiliser leurs véhicules avec des
conséquences sur l'activité de ces
stations
illustration avec ce reportage à
montigny le bretonneux de nicolas landry
et nicolas kirillovitch c'est un
paradoxe économique causée par la crise
sanitaire du coc vite 19
le prix des carburants à la baisse mais
une station-service déserte confiné et
limitées dans leurs déplacements les
citoyens utilisent de moins en moins
leur véhicule
hier matin ils avaient à se demander
dans l'après-midi à des personnes qui
venaient parce que les gens étaient
confinés chez eux
aujourd'hui des psaumes ap 2 4 kg qui
sont passés la station parmi ses clients
ce couple dit ni mon teint sortie avec
l'autorisation de déplacement
dérogatoire pour des raisons médicales
je vous souhaite un besoin et comme on a
besoin de se déplacer pour des raisons
médicales
on est obligé de
d'avoir du carburant on le fait que le
prix shaw basse et c'est une bonne
nouvelle mais bon je pense que toute
façon on a besoin de carburant des
conditions de travail adaptées aux
salariés de cette station service gel
hydroalcoolique et gants de protection
les précautions sont prises pour se
protéger ça change beaucoup parce que
les clones et rompt pas dans nos
boutiques achetées continue vers l'est
mais un peu à l'écart des boutiques pour
qu'on puisse 3d édition la seule chose
qui change ce qu'ils vont pas pourquoi
je suis dans la boutique avec defourny
soir ils viennent une dépose de colis
des eaux et m le bon de commande ici en
point qu'une fois qu'ils sont partis en
rond que le choléra dans la boutique
pour le moment la station service est
ouverte aux horaires habituels
avec le ralentissement de l'activité le
temps de travail des employés pourraient
être réduits durant cette période
exceptionnelle l'idée a germé sur les
réseaux sociaux chaque soir à 20h se
mettre à sa fenêtre ou son balcon pour
applaudir le personnel soignant engagés
dans la lutte contre le coronavirus l
initiative a débuté hier partout en
france ce moment d'hommage a été
observée pour la première fois dans les
yvelines des applaudissements ont pu
s'entendre notamment à rambouillet à
poissy et saint-germain-en-laye exemple
avec pierre-alain qui s'est mobilisé à
saint germain en laye il nous a partagé
sa vidéo et vous aussi n'hésitez pas à
nous partager vos vidéos hommage comme
ici expérience de confinement ou encore
témoignage elle les soignants qui sont
mobilisés en première ligne pour
remporter la guerre contre le coc vide
19 mai le personnel vient à manquer
comme à l'hôpital mignot le centre
hospitalier de versailles l'un des deux
lieux de diagnostic du coronavirus dans
le 78 est à la recherche de renforts
sont nécessaires des infirmières
diplômées d'état et des infirmières
anesthésistes et des manipulateurs radio
des techniciens laboratoires et des
aides soignants atv 78 souhaite bon
courage et affirment tout son soutien à
ce personnel soignant bravo à vous elle
nous vous en parlions hier
l'établissement français du sang
poursuit ses collectes en cette période
de confinement vous pouvez donc sortir
de chez vous avec une dérogation
pour donner votre sang ou vos plaquettes
le fs doit collecter et 1700 donc par
jour en ile de france
or depuis la semaine dernière la
collecte a déjà chuté de 13% nicolas
kirillovitch vous êtes présents sur le
site d'une collecte à rambouillet les
gens reste-t-il mobilisés dans le sud
yvelines malgré cette période de
confinement et bien c'est assez étonnant
instinctivement on aurait pu croire que
les gens ne se déplacerait pas pour
cette collecte de sang et des plaquettes
c'est tout le contraire ici à
rambouillet il ya une queue comme si
c'était un commerce alimentaire tout le
monde respecte les règles sanitaires en
respectant un mètre ou deux mètres pour
la queue et puis évidemment à
l'intérieur toutes les règles aussi
sanitaires et d'hygiène sont respectées
tout le personnel pour la collecte est
équipé d'un masque de gand et donc
beaucoup de monde des genres a souri à
l'intérieur du fait de toutes ces de
toutes ces règles
selon les chiffres de le fs6 les stocks
ne sont pas mauvais aujourd'hui il
pourrait l'être du fait du confinement
c'est pour cela qu'ils appellent les
gens à se mobiliser
les produits sanguins ont une durée de
vie très limitée 7 jours pour les
plaquettes et 42 pour les globules
rouges donc s'il n'y a pas d'inquiétude
aujourd'hui point il y en avoir dans 15
ou 20 jours si le confinement se
poursuit il faut donc rester absolument
mobilisés pour cela rien de compliqué il
faut s'équiper de cette fameuse
dérogation que vous connaissez déjà mais
très bien et cochez la troisième case
celle qui mentionne un déplacement pour
motifs de santé
si vous avez ça sur vous toute légalité
aucun problème pour aller donner votre
sang c'est très important pour savoir où
se tiendra les prochaines collectes dans
les yvelines et près de chez vous un
site internet dont 200 points est fait
ce point soins sante.fr des collectes
sont notamment prévus à feucherolles
dans les yvelines vendredi à saint
germain les châteaux forts et saint rémy
les chevreuse la semaine prochaine
restez donc mobilisés et nicolas quere
lovitz avec mélanie poquet pour les
moyens techniques vous le voyez tv 78
qui fait son possible pour garantir tout
de même dans ce moment particulier une
continuité de l'information pas facile
de faire vie
un média au quotidien avec un
confinement nécessaire et aussi et moins
de sorties sur le terrain le problème se
pose aussi pour nos confrères de la
presse écrite locale
exemple avec l'hebdomadaire toutes les
nouvelles qui est sorti en kiosques ce
mercredi
mélanie poker interrogé alexandre marqué
journalistes pour ce média sur le
secteur de saint quentin en yvelines
alexandre une première question plutôt
personnelle mais en tant qu il dit noah
comment vivez-vous les confinements la
coupe air un peu compliqué une famille
avec deux enfants dont un petit garçon
d'un an
donc c'est pas forcément évident faut
s'adapter
il ya le télétravail ok j'en avais
jamais devra montrer c'est la première
fois donc il ya de la situation au jour
le jour
voire à leur sort par heure donc
beaucoup trop fade ap
et comment c'est adapter le travail de
la rédaction parce que le métier de
journaliste est un métier de terrain
avant tout c'est plus compliqué qu'il
restait un bouclage normal la vie mardi
matin on a une conférence de rédaction
avec nos cercles avec notre directeur
pour voir comment on allait faire gagner
on a dû lui globalement qu on allait
tout faire du télétravail et que on
allait maintenir le site internet
soixante dix huit actuellement notre
journal papier qui paraît tous les
mercredis avec une pagination réduite
on va étudier donc de maintenir le
journal mercredi prochain avec au lieu
de faire une édition par secteur c'est à
dire une édition pour versa une motion
pour rambouillet une édition pour mende
et une édition pour sa part au relais on
va faire une émission commune en fait
outre les gens donnent les yvelines vont
contribuer dans le journal de bertha et
on trouva du menton 3 du saint germain
on trouvera du poids s'il y retrouvera
du rambouillet on voit là on s'est
adapté comme ça
pour ce qu'ils peuvent ou ceux qui le
souhaitent on va encore essayer de faire
encore quelques reportages par exemple
moi j'étais ce matin sur le marché ne
mord pas où j'ai fait un reportage sur
le marché qui continue à vivre malgré le
coroner
alors quelle est la suite pour votre
journal on maintient les publications on
les réduit
balou dit oui on va continuer à publier
dans l affaire teint du coup j'essaie de
faire des articles
le cliché de en récupérant des photos du
gua dément des problèmes et pas toujours
évident on va continuer à faire les
reportages quand on peut par exemple les
conseils municipaux d'installation des
nouveaux maires on va chez willkie et
d'y assister
même si certains sont à huis clos où si
on n'est pas de les faire play internet
via facebook live ou choses comme ça
mais c'est vrai que là c'est vraiment au
jour le jour quoi parle déjà de faire
une belle édition une édition pour
mercredi prochain
pas besoin d'un petit coup de froid et
puis la fonction comme d'autres
confrères ceux du parisien ont dévoilé
dans leur édition du jour une toute
autre actualité même si les écoles sont
actuellement fermés c'est le palmarès
2020 des lycées concocté grâce aux
indicateurs de l'éducation nationale
mais aussi avec une valeur ajoutée
c'est-à-dire la capacité des
établissements à faire progresser leurs
élèves
deuxième l'an passé c'est le lycée
international de saint germain en laye
qui arrive en tête du classement dans
les yvelines cette année il comptait
quatorze sections internationales
la surprise de ce palmarès la deuxième
place du lycée d'hôtellerie et de
tourisme de guyancourt un établissement
technique et professionnelle et qui
accueille 1400 jeunes 100% de la
promotion de l'an passé a obtenu son
baccalauréat enfin le lycée militaire de
saint cyr l'école complète le podium
il dépend du ministère de la défense
dans ce palmarès on retrouve aussi en
huitième position
le lycée de la plaine 2 nov la trappe et
le lycée jean vilar à plaisir c'est la
fin de cette édition spéciale merci de
l'avoir suivi on se quitte avec cette
image du jour le parc des sources de la
bièvre à guyancourt celui est
habituellement fréquentés par les
passants les joggeurs et les étudiants
de l'ub est ce qu est vous le voyez il
est totalement vide en ce deuxième jour
de confinement en france elle ne
l'oublié pas restez chez vous c'est
essentiel belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]